right now we're speaking about a time
that's 300 000 years after the events of
the Big Bang but you're looking back
even farther than that by looking at the
effects of the gravitational waves on
the microwave background and that's what
you built the telescope for in the South
Pole so imagine you're in a room right
now you're looking around your room you
have a horizon Beyond which you can't
see it's called the walls of the room
that you're in but if something happened
outside let's say somebody lit off a
firecracker outside of the room that
you're in you couldn't see it with light
but you could hear it with sounds in
other words you can see things that are
farther away and as we initiated our
conversation something that's farther
away we're seeing light from when it was
more primitive when it was older when it
was more distant means it translates by
this finite speed of light to an older
more primitive existence if the
explosion was loud enough even if you
were deaf you could detect the movement
of the walls that's right yes and so
I've heard that you know people in the
FBI you know they use the vibration of
Windows bouncing a laser off the windows
because people inside the room are
talking it's causing reverberations of
the glass and they can read out and
transduce the Sonic vibrations of the
air molecules using the reverberations
of glass and bouncing a laser off it as
I said we can go back from Friday today
13.8 billion years that someday we can
go back and that first three minutes of
that day formed the elements all the
hydrogen that's in your body's water all
the hydrogen that's in the oceans of the
entire planet and all planets perhaps
all of the hydrogen was formed in that
first three minute period
foreign